for Andre morovsky he'll dust it off take it
in good pass for Dunn his shot sealed off by
terasoft off the pipe Jaden Schwarz Duman cross
ice mccan ready shoots it a singer off teras off
and maybe off Damon Severson too out to Center
unfortunately yes yeah me too me too trying to
clear out a loose Puck on the penalty kill lson
fought off by terasoft verovski good retrieval
lson vinc done fought off again by terasoft
who was shaky in Columbus a couple of weeks
ago big rebound there want to continue to get
to that area that should be on the on the bench
everybody talking about a big hit there by
cylinder up high singer was the guy who took
out Matty bers and Columbus and then Vince Dunn
took care of that good stop by cord diegor chikov
Bean with a shot caught by dord no further play
bean made a couple of good plays in this game
player drafted by Ron Francis in Carolina
2016 dord says no on that shot by Andrew
Peak Johnson to the point prover off a tip
right on to court seals it baronov right out
in front pass it's just a pass and there you
see it hits dord right in the crest and Vince
stun hard around by terasoft Schwarz for lson
Adam lson Vince done a shot fought off again by
terasa he is spinning out rebounds tonight Shan
carali will feed it wide up to court look out the
big cat is there Adam Larson Dan forth stopped
by dord on the short side and Larson will take
over Jordan Everly marked there by Andrew Peak
and now waiting at the point as Vince Dunn York
Strand Dunn to the outside mccan Dunn gets it
York Strand it's tipped in Alexander wiberg and
Jordan Everly through the slot and thans home
Everly gets it the Kraken off and running Puck
retrieval net front presence with Everly and wber
and sometimes JT when you go to the net and your
sticks on the ice sometimes it just hits it and
that's exactly what happens to es it just grazes
the top of the stick blade and they don't ask
how folks they just ask how many sson cuts it
off ftil he gets it he's stripped by gour look
out look out it's a breakaway a partial break in
marchenko from well out Duman cut off the angle
dord took care of the rest broken up Alexander
texier BN in France out through Center he'll
take it wide shovel in and scooped up by Joey
dor and forth to the outside of Tatar he'll
wrap it in texier is there good sweep check
by Brian Duman Tomas Tatar off the board's not
out yeah now he's out three onone Everly for the
front McAn there he is he scores that's hockey
baby that's points and six straight for Jared
MCC two nothing Seattle watching that area right
there we're going to go go back and slow it down
because he jumps in on to thas Tatar Tatar gets
it to es and then Jared mccan goes short side
beautiful pass what a release two nothing lead for
the Kraken well it's all about the release on and
off the stick he takes too much time you're going
to give the goal tender a split second to get back
mle Sho Casino Resort power play number two dun
downhill a bit McAn he'll Rim It Off all the way
back Oliver Bor strand bumper slot by Everly
mccan stopped by teras off Everly the rebound
scor two goals three points so far for Jordan
neverly 3 nothing Kraken loose puck in this
first period has been the Kraken shoot the puck
big rebound we talked about it earlier rebounds
are out there I mean you got to look at that
shouldn't be a rebound you got to be able to
control that one and fortunately enough the
rebound is there the battle level getting to
the front of the net I think that's one though
if you're a terrab you want to melt that down
cuz mccan tolven and will settle it Bean gourds
all over him out in front oh teras off what a
stop that time on Ellie tolven for the Kraken
watch Ellie right there yeah that puck kind of
got him on the heel of the stick that's why he
didn't shoot it right away [Music] I was rolling
too that's what it was Schultz will settle it for
Seattle Justin sends it back for Brian Duman out
through Center Ice Here Comes Jordan Everly for
three it's shouldered Along by terasoft oh that
was by him Johnny that was by terasoft and he
just got a piece of it quick here there's es
about 42 feet and then right there oh right off
the arm stuck his blocker out there Damon Severson
marchenko off the goal post now Severson Kent
Johnson shot taken swallowed up by dord by the
Blue Jackets there's the shot by marchenko sounded
like from up here JT the bench got excited there
when Matty sold out and blocked that shot oh yeah
they definitely get up for a block like that ginaa
scores on the short side jagor chikov 1248 left
to go in the third period Columbus is on the board
right part of your screen chov gets his Puck kind
of shoots it right under the stick blade of Justin
Schultz did that like it did maybe did that go
off the shaft of the Stick of Schulz the puck
was fluttering a bit so once it yeah once it
left the stick and he picks up his 13th goal
of the season now a chance tolin and right in
stopped by terasa to the slot good stick by
sson he gets it out there's Ellie tolven with
a great chance forand backand lots of gourd
from alexc gains The Zone a shot patted
down by terasa twice G the followup done
to the outside sings it deep in the zone
going to schooling and Yanni gets one as
you called it Johnny there's one and he gets
another one right there right off the right
pad that might have been going wide sponsorship
yeah Stephanie Henderson ask in honor of kids
night what age is the best to start playing
hockey her nephew turns five today he went
to the game the other day chikov scores
402 left with a bullet and now it's very
interesting it's one but then they lose the
puck chikov gets in between wenberg and
alexc and then oh what a dart that is that that
is an absolute Dart 340 on the clock what was 3
nothing Seattle is now 3-2 Kraken tolin and
terasoft says no on Matty bers story there
Johnny did you take a a look at this two-on
one and a redirect there by Maddie Stephanie
Henderson wanted to know what's the best age
rinsky serson blocked by Yanni gour it comes
out huge play by Yanni 20 seconds left Seattle
by one marchenko denied by wiberg Tenth [Music]
bull wow everybody can exhale
was that wenberg at the Blue
Line completing the home stand on kids
night two seconds on the clock that's
cracking hockey Baby Tonight a 42
win over the Columbus flu jackets